this is the shuttle arrow the river
winds through the city of Basra here in
southern Iraq who was once one of the
most important waterways in the Middle
East
yeah lies the great vault of faster the
crossroads of the world's trade it fed
dozens of canals throughout Basra and
are in the city the nicknamed the Venice
of the Middle East
it made Basra the symbol of Iraq's
growth and prosperity today it's the
second largest city with over 4 million
people and with these oil fields and the
only deepwater port in the country it's
also the economic center about 80
percent of Iraq's revenue comes from
here but this is what Bosphorus canals
look like today in the summer of 2018
they were choked with debris or raw
sewage and rotting garbage that was
poisoning the city's residents about a
hundred thousand people were
hospitalized because of water related
illnesses Basra now represents a crisis
that's been looming over Iraq for
decades the country is running out of
water that's because it neither controls
the flow of its rivers or has the
infrastructure to clean it and it's
standing in the way of Iraq's recovery
[Music]
the waters of the two great rivers
Tigris and Euphrates are indeed the
waters of life almost all rocks water
comes from two rivers to Euphrates and
the Tigris which run down most of the
country then converged here to form the
Shatt al-arab before emptying into the
Persian Gulf along the way these rivers
provide drinking water to these cities
and irrigate farms and marshlands here
the rest of the country is mostly desert
a vast network of infrastructure is used
to generate power distribute the water
and clean it that includes dams canals
and water treatment facilities but this
system is delicate anything that affects
the amount of water flowing down these
rivers or the infrastructure around it
can have massive consequences over the
last few decades both have taken a hit
Iraq relies heavily on these rivers but
it doesn't control them both rivers
begin in Turkey about 71% of Iraq's
water comes from there while Syria and
Iran add another 10% as the rivers move
south which means 81 percent of Iraq's
water is controlled by its neighbors and
they've been keeping more and more of it
for themselves since the 1970s Turkey
has built at least 20 dams on the
Euphrates and the tributaries that feed
it including the Ataturk Dam the fifth
largest in the world which provides
electricity and water to its growing
population syria has built several dams
to both countries are holding the river
hostage
today only 1/4 of the Euphrates normal
flow reaches Iraq the same thing is
happening on the Tigris turkey is
building a number of dams here including
the illa Sudan when it was close to
completion in 2018 it blocked so much
water that residents all the way down in
Baghdad could cross the Tigris by foot
[Music]
to make matters worse many of the
tributaries that feed the Tigris begin
in Iran and there they've built 600 dams
in the last 30 years and dozens are
under construction all of this means
that Iraq the furthest country
downstream isn't getting enough water
there's less to drink irrigate crops and
generate electricity it also means the
rivers are more contaminated at a normal
flow water can dilute a lot of the
toxins and sewage that gets dumped into
the river but when levels are low these
pollutants become more potent plus the
weaker flow allows salt water to move
upstream from the Persian Gulf which
kills fish and crops all of this puts
more pressure on rocks infrastructure to
distribute and clean the water the
problem is much of this infrastructure
has been destroyed and Iraq hasn't been
able to rebuild it
there are been three devastating wars in
Iraq in the last three decades just two
hours ago Allied air forces began an
attack on military targets in Iraq and
Kuwait the Gulf War began when Iraq's
ruler Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait a US
ally the u.s. led a coalition to
retaliate with airstrikes we are
determined to knock out Saddam Hussein's
nuclear bomb potential destroy his
chemical weapons facilities much of
Saturn's artillery and tanks will be
destroyed but they also bombed two rocks
infrastructure including four
hydroelectric dams which in turn
disabled the water treatment facilities
that relied on electricity a sewage
treatment plant and Baghdad was also
bombed causing sewage to flow into the
Tigris poisoning the water supply for
southern Iraq this UN report said the
war reduced Iraq to the pre-industrial
age and that the country would face an
imminent catastrophe
thank them how it was done little woman
Adama Saddam survived the war but the UN
imposed strict sanctions freezing rocks
bank accounts and restricting what it
could import including construction
supplies and water purification
chemicals then Saddam made things even
worse in 1993 he was fighting rebels in
these marshlands
despite the post-war water crisis he
weaponized the water here by diverting
the rivers away from the marshes over
the years this whole area was drained
and turned into a desert thousands
reportedly died and at least a hundred
thousand people were forced to leave by
the early 2000s Iraq's water supply
continued to shrink while infrastructure
failed thousands of Iraqi civilians had
died from water related diseases like
cholera typhoid and dysentery
then in 2003 the u.s. returned with a
full invasion of Iraq
this time they quickly topple Saddam's
regime and installed a temporary Iraqi
government but the invasion further
damaged the country's infrastructure 40
percent of Iraq didn't have access to
clean water and 70 percent of sewage
systems needed repair a few months after
the invasion so the u.s. and Iraqi
governments announced a huge
reconstruction plan to rebuild
infrastructure it planned to bring safe
water to over 23 million people and
triple Iraq's water treatment capacity
but by 2006 the program had only
delivered safe drinking water to over a
third of the people it intended to
anoraks water treatment capacity was
still an eighth of the program's goal
millions of dollars were lost because of
mismanagement and corruption
reconstruction was a failure meanwhile
in a rock tonight more deadly violence
and what appears to be a concerted
effort to spark a new civil war they're
inching toward a new civil war many fear
falling apart the government is
collapsing the violence is starting
we're seeing all the symptoms of the
civil war in Iraq starting up again by
2011 Iraq was still unstable when the
u.s. pulled out his remaining troops
creating a dangerous power vacuum which
was quickly filled by a violent
extremist group called the Islamic state
their tactics deepened Iraq's water
crisis further they advanced down the
two rivers capturing strategic points
taking control of Iraq's water supply
and turning it into a weapon like this
dam in Ramadi controlling the water flow
cut supply to pro-government towns down
stream making it easier for Isis to
attack water the ultimate weapon
in this blistering desert Isis also
poisoned water supplies with oil here in
the city of tikrit and destroyed most of
this barrage in Fallujah by 2018 Isis
had lost most of the territory and
controlled but the damage to Iraq's
water was already done if the country
was going to recover it had to rebuild
this system and fast so the Iraqi
government announced a massive hundred
billion dollar reconstruction effort in
2018
but by the summer the water crisis came
to a head at the southern tip of the
country in Basra where the river was
dangerously low and toxic deadly riots
erupted in Basra government buildings
were burned and many called for the
prime minister to resign
[Music]
how are you mr. Watanabe
yeah Jerry - Jerry Selina and photo Jana
total freedom artisan my money
Jana Miss America live despite being the
economic center of Iraq Basra had been
ignored and left to deteriorate the
Iraqi Commission of integrity which
investigated corruption found that 13
water desalination plants that had been
donated to Basra in 2006 never opened
about 600 million dollars was pledged
for water projects that were never
completed and Basra sewage network was
supposed to receive a multi-million
dollar upgrade in 2014 but it was still
leaking into the Shatt al-arab in 2018
despite the uproar against corruption
and the lack of public infrastructure
Iraqis continue to suffer year after
year the water crisis has gotten worse
and Basra once a symbol of growth and
prosperity has come to represent what
could be Iraq's biggest battle ahead if
the country wants to rebuild it first
needs to stabilize Basra and bring clean
water to its people
[Music]